forum è una parola che ha diverse
sfumature di significato
in questo caso è l'acronimo di una
missione satellitare
quando abbiamo pensato a questo nome
abbiamo pensato proprio al forum di
discussione su quello che è un argomento
che è diventato in questo gli ultimi
anni un argomento molto caldo che sono
cambiamenti climatici
l'opinione pubblica è stata resa
consapevole che l'aumento di temperatura
sta uscendo rapidamente da quella che è
la per abilità naturale del sistema
testimoniata dai record storici ava
house is on fire è il grido di allarme
più forte più una denuncia che è stata
fatta negli ultimi anni stabilito il
problema il dibattito si è spostato
rapidamente su capire chi è la causa
all o che cosa sta causando questo
cambiamo il cambiamento
purtroppo il sistema climatico un
sistema molto complesso e fatto da
tantissime interazioni all'interno
dell'atmosfera tra le nubi gas presenti
ma non solo anche con
la superficie terrestre e gli oceani e
anche con lo spazio qualche c'è qualche
modo proprio perché l'aria è l'unica
materia che ci separa dalla nostra
stella più vicina a noi riceviamo
energia dal sole quindi l'atmosfera anni
in interazione col sole in qualche senso
e quindi lo studio cambiamento climatico
che è molto complesso comunque ha dato
già delle risposte
l'uomo è la causa principale di questo
cambiamento è noto a tutti che
l'industrializzazione ha immesso in
atmosfera grandi grandissime quantità di
gas cosiddetti gas serra anidride
carbonica il metano questi gas vanno ad
alterare l'equilibrio energetico del
pianeta e fanno aumentare la temperatura
questo è la problematica del clima è
legata quindi al quello che è il
bilancio energetico dell'atmosfera
quindi dobbiamo essere in equilibrio con
l'energia e ci arriva dal sole il sole
illumina la terra quindi la nell'utero
eletto nel visibile arriva dell'energia
parte di questa energia viene riflessa
dalle nubi e dalle superfici delle
ghiacciate o innevate delle montagne de
poli altra il resto dell'energia viene
assorbita la terra per il fatto di
essere un corpo caldo è una legge fisica
e mette nell'infrarosso e mettere già
nell'infrarosso questa energia viene
dispersa negli spazi
il problema è che ci dovrebbe essere un
equilibrio tra le leggi a chi entra e
nelle giacche esce in modo tale che il
sistema non si modifica e quindi la
temperatura media rimanga costante
quello che succede a meglio delle nostre
conoscenze adesso è che questo
equilibrio non è mantenuto noi abbiamo
circa 340 watt per metro quadro che ci
arrivano dal sole circa 100 watt per
metro quadro
sono riflessi che l'albedo del pianeta
il resto viene assorbito la terra
nell'infrarosso e mette 239 batte sul
metro quadro
facendo la differenza la differenza non
è zero e 0.5 watt per metro quadro mezzo
basta mezzo watt
c è molto piccola permetto quale però se
noi lente creiamo su tutta la superficie
terrestre sono centinaia di migliaia di
gigawatt quindi l'energia intrappolata è
un'energia della guardavo le quello che
è il problema è che il clima dipende
fortemente da questo numero ma non lo
conosciamo con bassa accuratezza
non abbiamo molta precisione sulla
misura di questo numero perché un numero
complesso da misurare da stimare alcol
tempo non abbiamo neppure elevata
precisione nel determinare esattamente
quale componente del sistema
contribuisce a un riscaldamento o
raffreddamento
questa è la problematica ancora aperta
e proprio su questa idea si basa lo
sviluppo e anche il concepimento della
missione forum che è stata ideata tanti
anni fa da un team di italiani del cnr
di cui io sono adesso il coordinatore e
sono stati necessari diversi anni di
ricerche di sviluppo anche di attività
prototipale con strumenti utilizzati da
terra purtroppo questo tipo di misura
può essere fatta solo in condizioni
estreme di bassa temperatura è bassa
umidità quindi siamo andati a farla
dalle under 5 mila metri di quota
attualmente c'è uno strumento in
antartide a 3.000 metri di altezza
oppure palloni stratosferici a 34
chilometri quasi lo spazio però per
avere una buona misura occorre avere
anche una copertura globale che può dare
solo il satellite
fortunatamente nel 2019
l'agenzia spaziale europea ha
selezionato questa misura menzione per
il lancio
adesso è in corso lo studio industriale
dell l quindi la realizzazione del
satellite
parte di un team di industrie europee e
satellite è previsto il lancio se tutto
va bene nel 2026
ma forum cosa cosa misurerà forum è
l'acronimo di far infrared out going
rogue e shawn understanding e monitori
quindi ambisce alla comprensione e al
monitoraggio del cosiddetto lontano
infrarosso la terra e mette
nell'infrarosso randy in un intervallo
di frequenze molto esteso
in un tale flusso e rappresenta le
lunghezze d'onda dello spettro
elettromagnetico che vanno da 15 micron
a 100 micron un micron un millesimo di
millimetro
quindi si sta parlando di lunghezze
d'onda che vanno da 15 millesimi a 0 1
mm è una regione intermedia fra le
microonde e il comune infrarossa in
questa regione la terra emette circa 50
per cento della propria energia quindi
perde 50 per cento dell'energia sotto
forma di lontano infrarosso
il problema è che questa energia per una
serie di motivi che non sto qui a
approfondire non ma stata caratterizzata
in maniera accurata dallo spazio gli
attuali sensori lavorano solo nel made
in fe rosso
questo quindi comporta che parecchie
informazioni non sono acquisite
quindi l'idea di forum proprio di
acquisire anche queste informazioni con
maggior accuratezza e coprire tutto
l'intervallo spettrale di emissione
cosa c'è nel lontano infrarosso che non
c'è nel medio e nel medio rosso ci sono
le i segnali di quasi tutti i composti
organici però nel lontano infrarosso ci
sono degli elementi più peculiari di
alcuni composti che sono fondamentali
capire o per capire meglio il
cambiamento climatico che sono le nubi
in particolare i ceri di alta quota
il vapore acqueo in particolare la
quantità di cuore di oppure acqueo in
alta atmosfera più o meno dove volano
gli aerei e le superfici ghiacciate dei
poli o innevate delle montagne
questo segna le parti con il segnale di
questi componenti è particolarmente
forte alle lontane grosse quindi forum
misurerà un po tutto questi questi
segnali e le misurerà con grande
accuratezza sarà un po come vedere la
terra con occhi nuovi
pensiamo un attimo per esempio a come la
terra pare usando gli occhi normalmente
visibile abbiamo a disposizione tutte le
le sfumature tutta la crew la
variabilità cromatica dal rosso fino al
dialetto e quindi la terra apparirà con
tutti gli oggetti della terra
appariranno ben identificabili da dalla
variabilità cromatica se ora facciamo
una cosa simile nell'infrarosso
ecco gli occhi non possiamo farlo
proprio perché gli occhi non sono
sensibili
dobbiamo usare degli strumenti e quindi
dobbiamo anche utilizzare in maniera
abitare a una scala di colori i falsi
colori da attribuire alle immagini in
modo da poter creare delle immagini è un
po come viene fatto nei termo scanner
dove si associano le coppie si associano
i colori freddi come il blu alle
temperature fredde o il rosso per le
temperature calde per creare delle
immagini termiche
se facciamo una cosa simile per
l'infrarosso associamo i colori blu più
freddi al made infrarosso e il colore
rosso allontani fra rosso beh se
guardiamo la terra senza misurare
lontano infrarosso vedremo un globo
blaster dove non sarà neppure facile
distinguere per esempio alcuni
componenti ad esempio i deserti dalle
nubi
cosa succede se aggiungiamo anche il
lontano infrarosso e quindi il rosso
avremo una variabilità cromatica molto
maggiore e quindi la possibilità di
distinguere meglio i dettagli in questo
caso ad esempio sarà possibile vedere
distinguere i deserti che contengono del
rosso dalle nubi
ora estendendo questo concetto alla
misura di forum forum non utilizzerà
solo tre colori mouse il utilizzerà
tutte le lunghezze d'onda quindi tutti i
colori presenti nella missione
infrarossa della terra quindi migliaia
di canali migliaia migliaia di colori e
attraverso quindi avrà la possibilità di
identificare i singoli componenti che
alle varie lunghezze d'onda
emettono del segnale quindi sarà
possibile capire se con più accuratezza
sia un componente tende a raffreddare il
sistema o tende a riscaldarla questo
consentirà di migliorare quindi la
conoscenza fisica del sistema e dei
processi che sono alla base della
costruzione dei modelli di numerici con
cui si studia l'evoluzione del clima a
questo questo quindi consentirà il
miglioramento delle stime climatiche e
in ultima analisi sarà di aiuto anche
alle politiche che dovranno essere prese
per contrastare il cambiamento climatico
e le varie azioni di mitigazione dei
cambiamenti
questo era il contributo che forum cerca
di dare alla tematica del cambiamento
climatico
grazie